noi pensavamo di essere al centro della
terra come esseri umani come specie
umana e che la terra fosse al centro
dell'universo è arrivato copernico e ci
ha spiegato che la terra non era più al
centro dell'universo come avevamo
pensato finora ma al centro c'era il
sole ferita narcisistica per l'essere
umano ma allora non siamo così centrali
come pensavamo di essere come ci siamo
consolati ci siamo consolati dicendo
siamo comunque una specie diversa
non siamo come gli animali non siamo
come le piante siamo veramente
differenti è arrivato darwin e ci ha
spiegato che in realtà anche noi abbiamo
un ceppo comune con alcune scimmie e
quindi sostanzialmente non sia una
specie così diversa perché anche noi
siamo animati altra rivoluzione
interiore
altra ferita narcisistica come sentirci
di nuovo speciali anche rispetto agli
animali
abbiamo pensato di essere molto
razionali e di essere gli unici che
riuscivano veramente a ragionare e ad
avere sotto controllo la nostra mente a
questo punto è arrivato freud e ci ha
detto che esiste l'inconscio ci ha
dimostrato più volte nell'arco appunto
degli ultimi anni che è del secolo
scorso che noi prendiamo delle decisioni
che non sono razionali abbiamo dei
comportamenti impulsivi che non
riusciamo a controllare e che quindi non
siamo così razionali come pensavamo di
essere come si siamo consolati di nuovo
da questa perdita incredibile pensando
di essere gli unici agenti nel mondo in
maniera ragionevole
quindi gli unici che riuscivano
veramente
ad agire ea interloquire a cambiare i
processi in maniera ragionevole è
arrivato alan turing aran touring ha
inventato il computer come sappiamo o
perlomeno ha gettato le basi di questa
che all'era che non stiamo vivendo
l'era della quarta rivoluzione che la
rivoluzione dell'informatica e
dell'informazione
noi siamo diventati al pari di animali
piante e oggetti connessi degli in ford
cioè organismi che consumano e producono
informazioni se tuttavia un
extraterrestre oggi dovesse arrivare e
cercare di leggere e cercare di capire
quindi quali sono gli esseri
maggiormente agenti sulla terra quindi i
dominanti con cui interloquire e
cercasse di farlo attraverso internet
penserebbe che sono gli oggetti connessi
che nel 2020 saranno 80 miliardi mentre
noi umani
saremo soltanto 7 miliardi quindi gli in
ford che maggiormente agiscono
attraverso internet nell'universo sono
gli oggetti
siamo totalmente smarriti siamo in una
dimensione in cui siamo spiazzati ci
sentiamo caduti nella tana di bianco
miglio e dobbiamo riconsiderare la
geografia la storia lo spazio il tempo i
millenials ma ancora di più quelli che
stanno diciamo crescendo dopo che
leggono tutto su digitale che già hanno
questa dimensione geografica
completamente diversa una percezione
dello spazio componente diversa noi
quale percezione avranno del tempo
avranno la percezione e l'hanno già di
un tempo presente
siamo nell'i per storia
quello che vedete qui è il professor
luciano floridi filosofo del settore
dell'internet institut di oxford che il
teorico della quarta rivoluzione della
storia dell'uomo è colui che ha creato
anche il termine iper storia per fare un
esempio di come sta cambiando veramente
la nostra concezione della storia
in base ai dati andiamo a vedere come è
stato finora
noi abbiamo avuto il primo periodo della
storia dell'uomo di cui non sappiamo
assolutamente nulla e della preistoria
perché non sappiamo nulla perché nessun
dato veniva registrato quindi non c'era
progresso non c'era linearità non si
poteva imparare dalle esperienze dagli
errori delle generazioni passate perché
non rimanevano scritte e non si poteva
costruire o immaginare un futuro sulla
base dei dati del passato in tutta la
storia dell'uomo fino all'invenzione del
computer
l'uomo a a un certo punto prodotto
invece 12 esabyte di exa byte di dati da
quando da quando ha cominciato a
lasciare diciamo traccia
da quando ha cominciato con i primi gilo
glifi c
i primi segni dei primitivi sulle
caverne i primi dati a cui rifarsi ed
andare a consultare per partire poi da
quel punto a costruire il futuro quindi
12 exabyte fino all'inizio del computer
180 exabyte dall'invenzione del computer
al 2006
se noi consideriamo che la storia parte
da quando abbiamo lanciato a produrre i
dati
pensate che sproporzione cioè 12 essa
bike e
fino all'invenzione del computer e con
l'invenzione v aumentano a 180 fino al
2006 dal 2006 al 2011
guardo alla mano perchè mi son segnati
per non sbagliare sono arrivati al nil
1600 exabyte voi pensate a livello di
storia quindi quanto la storia in
qualche modo se dovessimo darle una
dimensione spaziale si è allargata
cioè noi abbiamo infiniti dati dal 2006
al 2011 che superano di migliaia quelli
di tutta la storia passata andiamo
avanti siamo entrati nell'era dello zeta
byte
quindi abbiamo avuto un salto che quello
che dicono appunto è esponenziale di
dati e noi fino al 2015 che l'ultima
diciamo così soglia studiata
dall'istituto di berkeley che ha fatto
questo questa analisi abbiamo prodotto 8
z byte di dati
questo cosa significa l'iper storia
diventa questa dimensione in cui
quotidianamente vengono prodotti nel
mondo cioè nell'info sfera cioè nel
nuovo ambiente e spazio geografico di
tutti gli oggetti connessi che producono
e consumano informazioni cioè linford
noi ogni giorno dell'info sfera
produciamo una mole di dati che è otto
volte tutte le biblioteche americane per
fare un esempio che hanno fatto gli
studiosi di berkeley
quindi il presente si allarga il rischio
quale abbiamo pensato sempre all'uomo in
termini evolutivi da quando è cominciata
la storia quindi insomma il primo è
quello che sulla fine della preistoria
e poi diciamo andiamo ad evolvere
e pensavamo fosse evolutivo in realtà
quello che può accadere è esattamente
l'inverso
secondo un altro filosofo il filosofo
che si chiama che è un filosofo
sudcoreano che vive e insegna a berlino
e che ha teorizzato per l'appunto
un'involuzione che va avanti con le
nuove generazioni che sostanzialmente
vivono un eterno presente anche noi in
qualche modo viviamo un eterno presente
cioè per fare un esempio molto semplice
quando non scriviamo un testo lo
scriviamo quando lo correggiamo prima
avevamo la brutta copia non si scriveva
a mano oppure a macchina e poi si
conservava una copia poi si riscriveva
finché non veniva la bella copia adesso
ogni volta che noi facciamo save sui
cambiamenti quello che c'era prima viene
cancellato questo vi dà un minimo
esempio della cultura in cui siamo
entrati ed è una cultura di immissione e
pro se cioè in cui noi processiamo
questa mole di dati che già ci sembrano
troppi specialmente a noi giornalisti
per essere qualche modo ordinati
ponderati e questi dati a un certo punto
diventano un eterno presente che è il
presente dell'azione quindi avere sempre
come dimensione solo quella del presente
e solo il tempo precisissimo che il
tempo dell'azione fa in qualche modo
scomparire il tempo in cui non c'era
l'azione il tempo dell'ozio ci insegnano
però gli antichi greci che questa
civiltà occidentale è nata sullo zio i
grandi pensatori erano quelli che
odiavano e avviando meditavano e
processavano nella loro mente i dati in
qualche modo costruivano le filosofie
e le civiltà del futuro ora il tempo che
intercorre tra due azioni è diventato un
tempo vuoto en dice questo tempo è
diventato da tempo dell'ozio a tempo
libero che va riempito con un videogame
con un acquisto con qualcosa che ci
faccia divertire che ci distragga dalla
non azione quindi questo tempo preciso
che il tempo dell'iper storia allarga a
dismisura il presente e diventa il tempo
dell'azione nel tempo eternamente
presente dell'azione passato e presente
e questo lo vediamo semplicemente anche
cercando i dati nei motori di ricerca
convivono al punto tale che nel futuro
probabilmente le persone non sapranno
più quando una cosa appartiene non la
sovrano più datare cioè quando
appartiene al passato e quando
appartiene al presente
pensate ora a tutto il sapere a tutte le
biblioteche a tutti gli archivi
a tutto ciò che alcuni studiosi ancora
vanno a studiare a ricercare e ad
analizzare ma che la maggior parte dei
giovani delle persone del futuro che
nasceranno un'era digitale guarderanno
più o meno come noi guardiamo il
colosseo e non li apriranno se non
estrarranno dati e senso
da ciò che non è digitalizzato tuttora
siccome non ci sono troppi fondi anche
in italia esistono parti di archivi
totalmente inesplorati parte di archivi
totalmente ignorati
quindi brani e parti di storia
raccontati e tramandati soltanto da i
vincitori potrebbero essere anche fake
news per essere
sull'attualità che hanno costruito la
storia ma qui i dati veri reali quelli
di verifica noi neanche ci riusciamo ad
aprire perché costerebbe troppo
impegnare delle persone dei ricercatori
che si fermano lì si mettono a studiare
tutti quei volumi senza sapere neanche
in parte cosa c'è dentro ci vorrebbe
archimede pitagorico archimede
pitagorico per anni e anni diciamo di
storie di topolino ha cercato di
inventare la macchina del tempo in cui
almeno si rimette in ordine quella
situazione vissuta da nicole kidman nel
film di others ma ci sembrava
fantascienza e invece no è arrivato un
altro scienziato un altro studioso è
anche un artista che ha inventato uno
scanner che si chiama replica questo
scanner si trova alle pf di losanna al
politecnico di losanna
lui si chiama fredrik caplan frederica
caplan ha avuto un'idea
diciamo un sasso nel mare dell'iper
storia per rimettere il tempo in
internet
lui ha preso tutta la biblioteca di
venezia l'archivio di venezia tutto
l'archivio di immagini di tutti i quadri
veneziani e li ha passati a questo
scanner velocissimo quindi mille anni di
storia certificata la biblioteca di
venezia gestita dalla fondazione cini e
quella che ha i dati più completi di
tutte le transazioni avvenute a venezia
chi abitava dove chi faceva cosa
qualsiasi cosa e fosse catastale
anagrafica tutto segnato per mille anni
quindi il più completo archivio in
questo senso al mondo o quantomeno della
società occidentale mettendoli in questo
scanner che presto sarà anche capace di
estrarre
senso dai libri chiusi è riuscito a
creare dei pattern che servono a
individuare lo stesso elemento in un
tempo e in uno spazio diversi costruire
quindi un immenso motore di ricerca
della storia di venezia che per fare un
esempio molto semplice da comprendere
potrebbe consentire oltre che ovviamente
agli studiosi di accedere e studiare
tutti i testi cosa che abbiamo detto
economicamente non abbiamo la
possibilità di fare o pochissimi ce
l'hanno di creare una sorta di google
map per restare nello spazio tempo
google map del passato
cioè io mi trovo a piazza san marco e
posso andare a vedere come era la piazza
400 anni fa
se ho abbastanza dati che abitava lì
dove adesso c'è un negozio di
abbigliamento di lusso quale bottega
c'era in quella che oggi è diventata la
caffetteria più nota della piazza ma
posso fare anche fare un'operazione del
genere tra le persone posso fare il
kinder di casanova con chi ha avuto
rapporti casanova come si è trovato con
le sue fidanzate con chi erano sposati
le sue amanti con chi erano sposate i
giovanissimi saranno come il pesce che
non sa cos'è l'acqua perché saranno già
nati nell'era digitale invece noi
possiamo vedere e possiamo cercare come
ha fatto fredrik caplan di trovare di
modelli e dei modi e delle tecnologie
per rimettere il tempo in internet per
far sì che i futuri abitanti della terra
i nuovi in ford che saranno umani e che
saranno in strettissima minoranza tra
oggetti che parleranno tra loro
sono sempre più senza l'intermediazione
dell'uomo possano avere l'idea della
linearità e del tempo che ha costruito
la nostra civiltà
grazie
[Applauso]